children in their Labs a plastic bag for
their belongings entire families setting
out for Armenia
these ethnic Armenians have decided to
leave the Karbach region for each person
what they take with them is different
some even left with only three
functional Wheels
others pack their bags on farming
equipment
most women had nothing to say many in
their old age were too distraught having
to move
Fighters here are putting down their
weapons as part of the recent ceasefire
with Azerbaijan
despite repeated assurances from the
azerbaijani government ethnic Armenians
have left in their thousands
people living in karabakh region are
citizens of Azerbaijan regardless of
their ethnicity their security will be
assured by the state
everyone knows why we're leaving this
man says
I don't know where we're going this
driver told us but some are hopeful
about their return
just visiting my family I'll come back
he says
it's not just Khan candy or stepanakat
where people are leaving from they're
also living from other towns and
Villages such as hojalay in the karabakh
region although thousands of people have
left but tens of thousands still remain
in a place they call home
ensuring space between azerbaijanis and
Armenians are Russian peacekeepers but
they're not the only foreign power
involved
at a groundbreaking ceremony the
azerbaijani and Turkish presidents laid
the foundation stone or a cross-border
gas pipeline which will run from Turkey
to Azerbaijan
Ankara is one of baku's strongest
military partners
I wholeheartedly congratulate to
Victorious azerbaijani Army for both its
historical success and its humanitarian
attitude towards civilians
[Music]
Azerbaijan officials say when Armenians
took over their lands in the 1990s it
was a bloodbath
but they are offering amnesty and safety
to ethnic Armenians who choose to stay
and after Decades of violence and
mistrust thousands of people are not
willing to take that chance
Azerbaijan
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera